مجموعه ساعات تخلد لحظات رونالدو المميزه
ابراهيموفيتش يتالق في الشوارع بسياره
نادره ادون بوتسواني يعرض ميداليته
الاولمبيه للبيع هذه الاخبار وغيرها
نقدمها لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
تلقى النجم البرتغالي هو قائد النصر
السعودي كريستيانو رونالدو ساعه ثمينه من
ماركه جيكوب بتصميم حمل احتفاله الشهير
وهذا بمناسبه اطلاق الشركه لمجموعه من
الساعات تحمل لحظات مميزه في مسيره
رونالدو ويبلغ ثمن الساعه التي اهديت
الكريس حوالي 115 الف دولار لكنها ليست
الاغلى في المجموعه اذ تعد نسخه
الاغلى بسعر 150 الف دولار
يبدو نزله ابراهيموفيتش قد سائمه من غيابي
عن الملاعب وقرر اهداء نفسه سياره يتميز
من خلالها في شوارع مدينه ميلان النجم
السويدي المعروف بحبه للسيارات قررت تغيير
سيارته فيراري اس اف 19 البلغ سعرها نحو
نصف مليون دولار بفرار التي يبلغ سعرها
حوالي مليون دولار وهي سياره نادره حيث
صنع منها 600 نسخه فقط
اعلن برشلونه رحيل قائده بوسكيس بنهايه
الموسم الحالي وهو النجم الوحيد المتبقي
من حقبه
سابق ليونيل ميسي دعم سيرجيو برساله عبر
حسابه على موقع انستغرام
5 في الملعب لكن خارج الملعب كان دائما هو
الرقم 10 وكان ثنائي قد فاز بالعديد من
البطولات معا من ثلاثه القاب لدوري ابطال
اوروبا وثماني بطولات في الدوري الاسباني
عرض العداء البوتسواني النيجي الاموس
ميداليه الاولمبيه للبيع بعد ايقافه لثلاث
سنوات بسبب تناوله ماده محظوره وتعد
الميداليه الفضيه التي حصل عليها اموس في
اولمبياد لندن الاولى في تاريخ بلاده
وبحسب الرياضي وبحسب الرياضي البوتسواني
لانه يسعى لبيع الميداليه مقابل ثمانيه
ملايين دولار مؤكدا لانه تلقى بالفعل عرضا
لشرائها باربع ملايين الف دولار